permettez monsieur certainement vous et
moi cet or si c'est très difficile de
trouver une table
oui enfin bref je pourrai toujours aller
en face mais l'ambiance était pas la
même oui c'est moins agréable on me
dirait que c'est tout le monde avait en
face c'est ainsi que ce ne serait pas
gay absolument je vous demande ce grand
monsieur
permettez garçon admis si je voudrais
vous demander est ce que le garçon est
aussi pour vous qui sert à mes amis
n'est qu'à du pardon non je je voulais
vous demander si le garçon était aussi
pour vous qui sert à mes racisme huchet
dans le glass bec
donc je vous prie de m'excuser il ya un
brouillard fois dans ce cas faire je
suis confus je n'ai toujours pas compris
et simplement savoir si dans ce cas fait
aussi le garçon était qui serra mais
rabat agri dans les tranches choc des
merdes à buck qu'elle dit oui que l'udc
que le garçon ait des votes dans non
écoutez je vais vous dire franchement
est ce que vous savez c'est pourrais me
rendre
il essaiera merabet
la bouche tu as certainement
certainement auriez certainement pas par
hasard donné l'émoi que je vous donne
oui ben oui donnez moi je lui porte et
lui porter quoi les dix mille francs
allez les dix mille francs et un les dix
mille francs
j'avais excusez moi je vais pas tout de
suite combustion excusez moi oui mais là
vous avez rendu à wasquehal et pardon ça
par exemple non mais il ma cravate et de
dix mille balles à bas
salut je viens à encore en ratifier
justement je voulais parler alors dit
moi je voulais savoir si pour toi aussi
le garçon était qui sert à maera munich
a dit oui quoi je voulais te demander
simplement si si le garçon était 6
moucher dans le glass bec
oui dis donc tu es ab a nommé rien du
tout mais non je te pose une question
bien simple je voudrais savoir si le
garçon était pour toi entre choc devait
retenir oui d'accord d'accord d'accord
mondiaux est alors alors dû me les donne
que je lui porte
oui mais tu lui porte quoi les dix mille
francs ah oui justement à ce sujet je
voulais te dire de petits mots voilà tu
connais pas tu tu sais la fille avec qui
je sors en ce moment c'est son
anniversaire
alors si je ne trouve pas dix mille
balles avant soir je suis foutu tu
comprends ce n'est qu'une femme je suis
obligée de temps en temps d'avoir un
petit geste tu comprends et je trouve
pas dix mille balles avant ce cas
comment m non maintenant tout arranger
ça tu sais moi ça me dérange pas je suis
un seul nom le cij ne peut pas